Welcome to the September version of my Q and A's.
And uh,
thank you very much for tuning in again.
Um,
hopefully we'll have an interesting discussion tonight.
I want to stop start that is with a demonstration of some new newly managed
technical wizardry.
I have a program that I developed with my colleagues that I want to talk to you
guys about for just a few seconds.
Some of you already know about this called self authoring and self authoring
helps people write about their past to guide it autobiography,
that's the past authoring program and to write about their virtues and their
faults.
That's there's to present offering programs and a future authoring program that
helps people write out a vision and a destination,
let's say an ethical destination for their lives as well as formulate a plan to
put that vision into,
to make that vision into reality.
And our experimental investigations have indicated,
for example,
that university students who complete this program,
even if they do it badly,
and I would recommend at least doing it badly,
increase their probability of staying at university by about 30% and it has a
positive effect on their grade point average as well.
So there's a fair bit of evidence that your personality is organized at the
highest level through articulated speech.
Some of that you can formulate internally by thinking and some of it you have to
do,
you can do by writing.
You also do that in discussion with other people.
But these programs are designed to break down the problem of articulating your
life in the past,
present and future into a series of steps that are at least in principle
manageable and uh,
uh,
thousands of people have done them and I think they're very helpful programs and
we spent a lot of time perfecting them,
I suppose to the degree that they are perfected.
Anyways,
I want to,
here's the high tech part of this.
You see that's the website self authoring.com and I've put a coupon together.
Um,
the coupon name is September.
So that's what you have to enter for this coupon.
And that gives you a 20% discount at self authoring.
So,
and now all this is even more high tech because this marker is in a different
color.
And this program is a personality test based on the big five aspect scale,
which is a scale that calling the young one of my students developed when he
worked in my lab along with Lena quilty.
And,
uh,
the big five aspects scale offers you a five dimensional readout of your
personality,
extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness and openness.
The classic big five and minute breaks each of the factors of the traits into
two aspects.
So you get a high resolution map of your personality that takes the test,
takes about a hundred questions,
takes about 15 minutes to do and you'll learn about yourself.
I think you'll learn interesting things.
I had my kids do repeated iterations of the big five aspects scale when they
were teenagers.
And I learned a lot about them even though I thought I knew them quite well.
I learned things that were very useful.
So,
um,
you can do that and maybe you'll understand yourself a little bit better.
And so
this is the site
and the coupon is September just as it was for self authoring
and that's 20% as well.
And you'll see that amazingly enough,
this advertisement I suppose,
which is what it is,
is in purple instead of blue.
And so that's another technological miracle brought to you by the Internet and
the intelligence of modern human beings.
So all right,
so we've dispensed with that.
So that's self authoring and understand myself and you might find those useful
and I hope you do so onto more,
um,
fall on different things.
I guess I just got back to Toronto yesterday,
I think it was yesterday.
I was out in western Canada.
I went to a family reunion on Vancouver Island and then a,
a reunion of sorts as well in Saskatchewan with my side of the family and a
finished the talk and Regina and Saskatoon as well,
which seemed to be relatively well received.
So hurray for that.
I've really enjoyed all these lectures that I've been giving.
And Tammy and I,
Tammy's my wife,
we visited 65 cities now on this tour and we're starting again on September 5th
we're going to go down the eastern seaboard.
There's 20 cities in,
in the northeastern us.
And then we're off to Europe for another 15 cities or so.
And then in February I think we're going to go to Australia.
And then in March and April back to Europe.
And then in May,
I'm going to spend four months diligently finishing up what I hope to be my next
book,
if assuming that I can get that done in that period of time.
And also that other opportunities,
let's say,
or distractions don't rear their head either positively or negatively.
And who knows,
right?
Because life is a very uncertain business.
I've really enjoyed the lecture tour a lot.
Um,
you know,
I've been speaking to audiences of about 2,500 to 3000 people and mostly about
the,
I would say mostly about the nexus,
the relationship between meaning and responsibility,
trying to make the case that because life is difficult as everyone with any
sense knows.
And because we can make that worse with our own stupidity and malevolence that
it's necessary to find a sustaining meaning in life.
And my sense is,
and I think people tend to agree to this,
is that the most sustaining meaning can be found a and the adoption of voluntary
responsibility.
So in attempts to decrease the suffering in life and to do things that are
worthwhile and admirable and to take care of yourself individually and your
family,
and to have a little bit leftover for your community and to have goodwill across
all those dimensions if you can possibly manage it despite the fact that there's
something in life to make people relatively bitter.
And then,
um,
as well the necessity of conducting yourself in a truthful manner.
Um,
making also the case to my listeners,
I suppose that that one of the most ancient presuppositions that underlies the
structure of Western civilization,
which is a very functional civilization in my estimation,
is the idea derived from genesis,
that truthful speech,
if you confront truthful speech,
if you confront potential,
the chaos and potential that is in front of you with truthful speech,
that you engender the order that is good.
And that's a fundamental ethical dictum.
It's,
it's,
it's a presupposition in some sense that the order that you bring into existence
in all the choices that you make will be the best possible order in proportion
to the degree that you conduct yourself in a truthful manner.
And so those ideas seem to be falling on very receptive ears and they are the
most resilient ideas that I think I've ever come across.
I mean,
I always take an ice pick and a hammer to any idea that I encounter and I really
do that diligently because I don't want to rely on ideas that can fall apart and
break,
especially when they're stressed.
And I don't see,
I don't,
I haven't come across ideas that are more solid than that.
I mean,
the first proposition,
you know that life is suffering and that we make it worse with our malevolence.
I think everyone understands that to be true.
But the second is that the best way to confront that is to shoulder
responsibility voluntarily and to live in truth.
I think those are even more powerful ideas because you could say that the cure
for a malaise or the treatment for a disease is more powerful than the Malaysia
Malays or the disease itself.
And If responsibility and truth are antidotes to suffering and malevolence,
then that means that they're there.
They have a power that's transcendent over suffering and malevolence and you
know,
it's so,
it's a very pessimistic viewpoint.
And the one hand,
because I'm stressing for everybody that is coming to listen to me talk,
the fact that life has an inalienable element of difficulty and,
and travail and suffering and all of that,
and you certainly see that sort of thing when you go to a family reunion.
You know,
like a lot of my relatives,
my parents' generation,
they're getting,
all of my parents are in their eighties now and,
and their friends,
some of the,
they have friends that are older and everyone's starting to suffer from the
inevitable deterioration that's associated with old age.
And it's very,
very trying and very difficult for people.
And it's,
it's in those situations that you see more clearly the fragility of life and
also the importance of having,
uh,
having a family that's functional and people around you that love you and all
those things that in principle can help sustain you through difficult times.
So anyways,
I'm here in Toronto for about 10 days,
got a lot of media interviews again partly to discuss the upcoming talks.
Um,
my book 12 rules for life still appears to be selling extraordinarily well.
it's quite
amazing.
All things considered.
It's approaching 2 million sales in,
in,
in the English version.
And um,
there are foreign versions coming out all the time.
So,
and I've also,
I'm also in the process of putting together the final arrangements for my next
book,
which I talked about.
So the plan is to,
to write,
I'm writing that now.
I've got it about half written,
maybe a little bit more expanding on the themes that I developed in 12 rules for
life and also extending them as much as I possibly can.
Um,
and I hope to continue writing during this period of touring as well so that I
can stay on top of my deadlines and then from May to September to spend most of
that time finalizing and editing and polishing and all of that.
And then hopefully the book is due in September and the current plan is to spend
September through December,
um,
likely concentrating on a return to the biblical lectures starting with exodus,
which is something I'm really looking forward to but haven't really been able to
turn my hand to.
The other thing I'm really thinking hard about doing,
I'd like to do a series of lectures and I don't know if I could do them publicly
or not,
but I might be able to finagle that in some manner.
I'd like to do a series of lectures on the sacred icons of the radical left.
So I'd like to do a lecture series on marks and Fuco and Derrida,
and then some,
some of the famous feminist too,
like Betty for Dan whose work I'm not a fan of,
um,
for a variety of reasons and do Judith Butler as well.
But I'd really like to concentrate on marks.
So,
uh,
one of the things I might duty for you guys tonight or two you have,
one of the things I might do to you tonight is I found a poem by Karl Marx that
is extraordinarily interesting and that might be worth reading if I can.
I just thought about doing that,
if I can scrape it up in time.
So let me just check very quickly and see if I can find it and then I'll get to
some questions.
Because after all,
this is a Q and a,
right?
That's the theory.
So.